[Music]
welcome to the recruitment mentors
podcast
this is the 15 minutes with a mentor
series
that we are releasing in line with the
recruitment mentors community opening
and in this series really simply we're
going to ask some of
the mentors from inside the community
seven questions in 15 minutes
i'm delighted to be joined by lewis
adams dunstan
he's one of the mentors inside the
community has been on this podcast
but for those of you that may not for
those other people listening that may
not know you lewis if you could do
a quick intro and then we'll we'll jump
straight into the questions
yeah absolutely thanks again for having
me initially um
i realized my watch is going off like
crazy here i'm not sure if you can hear
that but
first and foremost uh my name is lewis
adams dunstan i've been in recruitment
for
over 10 years now i've worked in every
role you could imagine from
entry level through to team lead to team
manager and i'm now the director of
business development at darwin
recruitment
in america amazing
first question what
was your biggest challenge in 2020
how did you overcome it and what did you
learn from it
yeah so biggest challenge is actually
something i didn't realize until
it hit me and that was fatigue so
i didn't really take any time off at all
for the for the entire year and got to
the end of the year looked at my
my vacation time and was like wow i've
i've maybe taken like four or five days
off
and i think that was a combination of
being at home like what was there to do
it's not like i could go on a trip it's
not like i could um
it's not i could do anything same as
anyone really and i got to the end of
year and
i realized actually i was being less
productive i was less motivated and i
was just generally fatigued
so i've always been someone that just
kind of tries to power through it
and i had three weeks of vacation time
and i took it at the end of the year
i'm not encouraging everyone to go and
take three weeks off
but actually it was really good for me
um i realized it is not like a one
size fits all solution for fatigue so i
just decided to switch everything off
everything um i played a lot of
playstation um i did a lot of eating
i worked out a lot um but it took me a
while to realize what i needed and after
after i took that time off i came back
energized motivated
um it gave me time to self-reflect on
things i did well and things i didn't do
so well so
don't take that for granted like when
you need time off take it
um because recruitment generally
speaking is a pretty high pressure
like very demanding role so there's so
much value in just giving yourself time
to rest
so that was my biggest challenge that i
didn't know didn't even know was
existent until
i just kind of hit a wall yeah i love
that so
yeah don't don't always think the only
path and option is to just power through
right
and i definitely felt about that over
the christmas period so
second question is this may tie in
actually but second question i have for
you is
like what working from home tip could
you share with other recruiters that has
had a massive impact on your
productivity
um routine is is the biggest thing for
me
that i still get up in the morning i
still go to the gym at 6am
i still do my hair straighten my beard
i still get dressed up as if i'm going
into the office um
i've created an office environment for
myself as well which is cool like
don't don't lose that mindset don't roll
over to the side of your bed grab your
laptop sit in your pants all day
and and then get showered at 8pm like
that's
a terrible habit and it and you're not
going to be successful doing that
so i think to build a successful mindset
you need to have a successful routine
and it doesn't really matter if you're
working remote or working in an office
you need you need to have one in place
so that that was that was the biggest
impact for me
what's been the most effective way for
you to win business in the last 12
months
um not not cold calling
um warm calling after i've found a
reason to connect
with a recruiter or a hiring manager and
what i mean by that is
not just looking at what jobs they have
open and saying
i can find a solution for you first and
foremost trying to understand the
business what they do
um putting time into researching the
individual who might be the hiring
manager or the point of contact that can
introduce you to the home manager
and approaching them in a personable way
so
don't just try and take all the time
look look at
look at their background complement them
if you've got something in common talk
about it
like make sure you bring in value but
try not to pitch your recruitment
services they've heard it too many times
eight and eight times in that day by the
way so like
be a little bit more innovative with
your approach and and you will
start to have conversations and
conversation are business development
opportunities even if you don't get a
job at
the end of conversation with a hiring
manager whether that's on a comment
on a post that they've created and they
respond to you whether that's getting
them on the phone whether that's
introducing someone to them
that's how i've measured my success in
in that respect and
i've started to forge some really good
relationships that now
are starting to turn into really good
business opportunities
love that so but this would be
interesting to hear from you actually
talking about routine and stuff like
what what habit or hobby did you start
in 2020
that you're going to continue in 2021
uh that's an interesting one
i think just the consistency in my in my
honesty it's not necessarily work
related per se but just consistency in
my gym
workouts um i typically trained twice a
day um
just because again there's nothing else
to do once you finish work outside of
watch films and play playstation
so that that was a habit i picked up and
it's just given me so much more energy
and i don't feel
fat and floppy at the end of it you know
like i'm not
getting to the end of remote working if
there ever is a thing and thinking i
just feel
i just feel terrible about myself so i'm
just making sure that i maintain
a healthy lifestyle and that creates you
know a healthy mindset when
when working in recruitment how has
everything else than that yeah um
we can't wait for these gyms to be open
in the uk trust me that it's absolutely
clear oh they're not they're open
no they're not not open sorry about that
yeah
so slightly different one here which do
you think is better
the first coffee in the morning or
the first pint post work on a friday
fine definitely yeah yeah no question
i've taught myself not to need caffeine
unless i absolutely like
i'm in a like a terribly exhausted space
um i don't think i'll ever teach myself
not to need a pint
but i
um right so this one's a bit different
this one's a bit of a scenario okay so
i want you to sort of share with us how
you'd approach this situational scenario
that you might find yourself in so
a bit of what you're talking about so a
particular business has been on your
target client list for over a year
right and you've had a couple of touch
points with them with different hiring
managers in this organization so
over that time you might have had a
couple of their
people in that organization like some of
your content on linkedin
or some of them may have received an
email from you or
even an introductory email that you
tried to reach out but through your
candidate network for your relationships
you managed to get one of the hiring
managers contact details
and you call them right and they pick up
and they answer
and they say hello who's this what'd you
say
what would your approach be
i think just pulling on the fact that
you've spent a year trying to get hold
of these people
you probably know way more about them
that they know about themselves if
you've been doing your research like
leading up to that point i wouldn't have
just been calling that person hoping
they picked up
i every time i wanted to to get hold of
them on the phone i would have had
something armed and ready
that i could find relevant so i would
very quickly introduce myself
i would not give them the recruitment
spill but i would very quickly out here
it's quite common to do it is talk about
perhaps one of their college degrees
or perhaps talk about their education
talk about something that happened with
a local team
letting them know who i am and maybe
just making a joke out of it like
i i'm pretty candid like i'll be like
finally do you know
i feel like you just gotta try and at
least turn it into into something and
not just go
right i've got sale now i finally got
them because they'll just go no
no stop selling to me find something
like that you can that you can
talk about a middle ground and then go
in with that approach that's just
it's a soft way to do a hard sell
yeah i like it last question question
seven
is so final question really is thinking
of when when recruiters have been
listening to this it's still going to be
in the first quarter of 2021
i'm sure everyone listening will be
thinking about i want to have a better
year this year right so would have
probably set some goals
for 2021 feeling motivated to like i
guess what and i'm sure you might have
said this to some of your team or even
to yourself like what's
what would your advice be to me if i
wanted to have
the best possible chance of achieving my
goals this year that i've set what would
you what would your advice be to me
i would say it's pretty common in a
working environment
to have the opportunity to celebrate
small wins
where you're in an office and you get a
high five you
grab that beer that you just mentioned
on a friday with your mates during lunch
or after work you can't do that right
now
so and that's very difficult to do on
your own right it's weird if you keep
high-fiving yourself
but you need to find a way to associate
like a celebration of some kind or a
ward of some kind with a small win
because i think that trains your mindset
into
understanding when you're being
successful
so find something that works for you it
could be
taking time off to go for a run it could
be
having a beer it could be anything
anything that you you see as a
celebration
associate that every time you have a win
because i think that'll that'll just
keep that motivation up knowing that
that you are making progress
so yeah that would be my advice
celebrate the small wins that you
no longer can do in an office space at
home
somehow yeah i like that and yeah i
think sort of celebrating celebrating
the process isn't it and and putting
more emphasis on that rather than just
the outcome i think is an interview yeah
an interview is a win
a conversation's a win like a
an offer accepted as a win like they're
all wins don't just wait for the deal
and then wait for the money just
celebrate them
love that lewis that was 50 minutes of a
mentor
11 minutes to be exact
lewis absolute pleasure thank you so
much and um
yeah excited for people to learn more
from you and about you so thank you
appreciate your time as always